all right so welcome back people of the
Internet to our dark arts playthrough of
Hogwarts Legacy thank you for being here
today and I need to check my quest page
to see what we should tackle next we are
getting closer we're not there yet but
we are getting very close to finally
getting to the map chamber as a
Slytherin which will unlock that trophy
for us
and we'll only have a handful more to go
but we still haven't gotten to any of
the places around the school
unforgivable spells or anything like
that yet but we have really been
focusing only on story stuff so far for
this playthrough someone from the
ministry guarding the school after the
incident all right so it is time for our
first potions class
with Professor Sharp
let's see how this goes
trailer Heights of both discipline and
intellect
by brewing a Wigan weld ocean
Mr takar can you tell us why this
particular potion might come in handy
yes Professor sharp the wig and weld
potion can be used to sterilize and even
heal a variety of injuries it can heal
some injuries but not all well done meat
well done law before today's class is
completed each of you will have brewed a
wig and weld potion of your own
you never know when you might need it
Wicked world's definitely an important
one that's for sure
definitely an important one to know
I was surprised that I thought there
would be more strong scenes like this
when crushing your ingredients like this
is really the only time you have to do
these little contextual things
one errant sneeze could be disastrous
which honestly I'm kind of okay with it
I know some people would have liked to
have done this every time but I feel
like after a while you would just be
you would want it to be how it is in the
room of requirement where you can just
make them right away and they're ready
to go like imagine if you had to do this
right here every time you made a weekend
weld
all right come on over sharp inspect it
tell me how I'm doing
I see most of you have not forgotten how
to stir
oh yeah Gareth
hmm
not an easy potion to brew thank you
Professor appreciate it
exploits in hogsmead hey Dylan thank you
dude the defensive endurance potion
Professor Weasley had you acquire the
recipe from Jay Pippins correct yes sir
good
for the moment you can find the
ingredients you need in my office but in
the future you'll be expected to provide
your own ingredients yes sir some can be
harvested from the plant you grow in
your herbology class and rarer ones can
be purchased
others however may be harder to obtain
and will require you to be a bit more
resourceful come and see me when you
finished Brewing
and we'll see if it was skill or luck
the first time around
all right and we had Dylan with those
gifted Subs Dylan thank you so much for
the five gifted
guys make sure you think Dylan if you
got one of those gifted Subs right there
tell them how much you appreciate it
enjoy your ad free viewing and all the
emotes on the channel
uh let's see Yes you heard correctly my
friend he wants me to get more
ingredients to brew another potion
brilliant
friend had been presented with an
extraordinary opportunity I'm Gareth by
the way Gareth Weasley bit of a prodigy
with potions if I do so so myself
pleasure to meet you that would have
been a good idea I feel like having you
do it the first time yeah she's my aunt
mixing the potion too close an eye on me
for comfort
but she can't be everywhere listen
anyone with a troll size brain can brew
an endurance potion I'm working on
something that's certain to be
spectacular I'm just missing one tiny
last ingredient that will add that extra
spark I suspect that's where I come in
you're as clever as I'd hoped
I simply need a single super feather as
you'll already all right dude we got you
his permission
for me
let's see I can get you that feather I'm
not sure that's a good yeah I'll get it
I'll get you I don't care as long as
you're starting we'll get it for you
we're Lord retro Mort We're Not Afraid
wait until you see what I'm brewing or
maybe I should have told him get it
yourself dude
what would be the most
Voldemort thing to say probably would
tell him to get it himself okay wait why
is this
mom girl fur just sitting here
I have a little note here
let's see from the aura office December
31st 1875.
oh this is so fascinating
specifically about Borgen and Berks I
wonder if this is when the shop first
came into uh existence borgenbergs has
had an increased amount of activity
outside of ordinary Shop hours
particularly in the wee hours of the
night with suspicious deliveries being
made to the Shop's back entrance even
when we know of the Shop's reputation we
are adding more Ores to join those that
have already been watching the shop you
are amongst the new additions further
instructions to follow
sharp will never notice guys he'll never
notice us taking all of these different
things
Ash Winder eggs I think that's what we
were supposed to be in here for right
and I heard another field guy page
outside
did you guys know these clocks
they're actually real like real-time
in-game clocks you know they don't they
don't match the time in the real world
that you can test it out when you skip
time
it's pretty interesting
all right so where am I supposed to go
now tell Gareth we got your feather
feather you wanted brilliant thank you
to take a moment to brew
you should get back to more Juris potion
and I'll tell you when this concoction
is finished
all right so I need to go back to the
adorous potion right here
hold on let's find this uh I think it's
for sharps or badge isn't it yeah
hello
oh maybe we can't get it right now
maybe we have to complete the assignment
first you think
all right so what did he want us to make
the address potion yeah that's it
30 seconds
just don't pick up the feather can you
actually do that Craig what happens if
you don't do it
does he have to go in himself
keeping it instead of giving it to him
yeah that would have been a good night
just no he can't have it sorry
all right let's take our dearest potion
now we add the mallow suite and
that's odd what's happening
wait here we go
we're gonna blow up in his face right
here
classic Weasley
[Music]
oh Sharp's not happy
that'll be points from Gryffindor again
Mr Weasley did not do this on his own no
I did it accomplice will answer to me as
well
Rebellion I still can't grab this
all right sharp I brood in the Doris
potion as you asked Professor I'm
surprised you had the time you seemed
rather busy helping Mr Weasley Brew
chaos that was too nice
I must retrain retrain my brain we are
Lord retro Mort
I'm surprised you had the time you seem
rather busy helping I don't know what
you mean sure what you're talking about
Professor you will not earn favor with
me by failing to take responsibility for
your actions
I suggest you heed my warning as for the
work you did today at your own cauldron
I will say you've done well I confess I
was skeptical given the advanced nature
of this class and the fact you're a new
student I'm glad I was able to meet your
expectations a rare occurrence and you
do well to remember that you're not a
potions Master quite yes sir in addition
to having a solid grasp of how to
combine various ingredients you shoot
twins to capture Gareth yeah good point
good point pay particular attention in
herbology the plants you nurture there
are often essential to the potions you
brew here now I recommend that you find
a safe location in which to practice
Brewing you cannot leave a hot cauldron
simply anywhere but are we all Kratos uh
welcome in welcome in they did have
something about that
in the in the latest update but I don't
think it was for
I thought they'd already fixed that
actually but
oh no you guys are right I think it's a
new bug
oh there it goes the prompt just wasn't
showing but it still let me pick it up
all right good deal
good deal glad it worked
hey chibi thank you so much for the sub
there welcome in welcome in enjoy your
ad free viewing on the channel
and also the emotes which I think we
just got an additional one approved I
just need to set it up
our deathly hallows emotes
and you can help scrub get to the
Courtyard past the pendulum if you don't
know it you'll see it easy enough and
don't tell anyone what you're up to
it's awesome
okay I think this is finally it I think
we have finally reached
the map chamber
with this next Quest and I believe this
is like the uh the one that is different
for each house too I think this is
jackdaw
if I remember correctly which I could I
could definitely be wrong but
I'd better keep an eye on high places
around happy to be here a and a first
time chatter too
good to have you good to have you yeah
so this mission is different depending
on which house
you are in
uh there are some similarities but some
pretty big differences as well
particularly with the Hufflepuff version
of this mission
all right well I'm not noticing too many
differences in terms of the loading
times on today's update
if any of you are watching this later on
YouTube guys there was a patch update
today with a lot of bug fixes and we are
playing on that updated version
well that's right we can we can activate
this one now too
so we have the spell
last time we did not have the spell we
needed
Rebellion
all right not hearing any others we
already got that one
already got the one that was right there
not the depulso yet
we do not have that spell just yet
yeah Akio does not work it's kind of
confusing because
there's revelio pages and then Field
Guide pages so like this right here good
example this one is a revelio page so
the only way to collect that field guide
page
is by doing that right there and then
you get the little description here The
Well of the four beasts
but then you also have just the random
pages that are flying around those you
can accio but you don't like get a
little uh there's no note or anything
with them
all right so right here mysterious note
scope knows about the book you found is
it missing something scrope does not
believe it is safe to speak out in the
open strope has left another note across
the bridge among the circle of rocks
take care tell no one about this scrope
who is scrope dude
he just contacted you
do you not remember he sent you a letter
that's funny because we see the scrop's
picture and hear his voice on screen but
I guess our character
doesn't actually have that luxury okay
we're here
where you at dude
supposed to find another letter I think
it said
maybe we need to wait till night time
oh wait wait wait there it is right
there
let me accio that
what
are we actually gonna have to stand on
top of this to
to retrieve this
how did scrope get up there he's way
shorter than I am
there it is almost there head for the
pumpkins just down from the stone circle
look inside one of them you may be able
to help pour broken-hearted scrope
ah I think I'll adjust the place yeah
that's a good way of looking at Anna all
revelio pages are Field Guide pages but
not all Field Guide pages are revelio
Pages indeed
that is correct
all right so going down to the pumpkins
I'm curious to see how this plays out as
a Slytherin because I have not watched
the full playthrough of any of the
others except Hufflepuff
for obvious reasons if you know you know
but if you don't know Hufflepuff gets a
pretty Epic Quest For This
all right so he said inside one of the
pumpkins there it is
the young Slytherin must be
exceptionally Curious by now indeed meet
scope at the water's edge by the Broken
docks down to the water's edge so how
long ago did he put these notes there
and he's just waiting
or is there going to be another note for
us oh man I'm so not used to
traversing the area without the broom I
keep wanting to hop on the Broom we
don't have it unlocked yet in this
Playfield
soon enough though soon enough
that's one thing that really surprised
me on my first playthrough is I did not
think
it was going to take so long to get the
broom
but it takes quite a while
welcome into the new followers welcome
in thank you all for being here hanging
out today there he is
all this way
the name scrope scrope serves the
Headmaster have been in the black family
for years apologies for the abundance of
notes scrub wanted to be sure you
weren't followed what's this all about
your notes mentioned the book I found in
the Restricted Section scrap can tell
you more in exchange for your help oh no
one is
Master's back
happy to undermine
Lord retro more
all right we gotta go with that one
undermining the Headmaster and getting
something in return
continue your script does not intend to
undermine the Headmaster in fact stroke
wants to surprise him
scrubs like mistress Apollonia black
okay
over 50 years ago before she died she
spoke with passion of pages read from a
book scrub suspects she took them to her
private Grotto
she was delirious at the end poor thing
mistook Belladonna for Elder Benny's
scrope tried to warn her I'm sorry to
hear that
but
how do you benefit if I find the pages
scrope believes that a treasured black
family ring is also in The Grotto scrub
wishes to give it to the Headmaster
Apollonia for bad scrope from entering
The Grotto long ago everywhere
scrub would not dare us take a long time
for help but when scrup learned you were
looking for those pages scrope thoughts
you might also find the ring
I'll go it seems this may help us both
what happened to your ear scrub is ready
you should have asked this group hoped
the young Slytherin would be willing to
help and take this toast to The Grotto
just down the coast and place it on the
pedestal there good luck
oh placing the toast
no way is this gonna be what I think it
is
hold on hold on hold on
I'm pretty sure this is the area where
my goodness that duck bug right there
hey let me buy
not even gonna mess with you dude oh no
there's another one there oh no
we can't swim as fast as we can run
oh mind me Doug Boggs don't mind me
come on come on come on come on no
all right fine I have to use a Wigan
weld oh wait can you not use wiggenwald
in water it's not working
it's not working
they're really following me in here
that's where it goes
no okay good there goes my health
all right refilling
a bunch of those Doug blogs I know
I guess I should have fought them but
it's all right we made it yeah so this
area super cool area right here
and I guess we need to place the toast
right here let's see what happens
oh what
no way
oh my goodness okay so there's something
behind here all along
all right a Polonia blacks Journal
could it be
a jackdaw
so yeah this is jackdaw's Quest no
matter which house at all connects back
to jackdaw
but you go about it in a different way I
was a student just like you about a
century ago how in the world did you
find
final self named scrope sent me said I
might find a black family ring here ah
I sold the ring a long time ago
poor scrope
can't say I blame him I stole all these
Treasures just can sell things oh when
he was alive
I thought a secret map I pilfered from
peeves would pique her interest
but she simply rolled her eyes what
would I want with yellowed old Pages
torn from a book
not my finest moment
hand them over I must insist that you
give them to me at once they're not here
I thought if Apollonia wasn't interested
perhaps it would lead to something that
would Intrigue her so I followed the map
to what I could only describe as an
enchanted Cave of some kind and
you see what happens next is that where
we're at right now here's an idea
why don't you
and I'll show you
oh you got it
why why the toast I have to ask this why
did I need the toast to get in here oh
that was apollonia's idea seems some
squids love toast they should have
taught you that at Hogwarts nice nod
there to the sear to the original series
all right how did you lose your head I
think I could guess
but who did it to you hey thanks Rooney
around when I suddenly sensed a
refreshing Breeze after that I felt well
light-headed
and if you do visit the cave be prepared
I can't tell you what for specifically
but you seem a perceptive sort
beware a light Breeze
all right I'll see you there the only
way for me to get those pages I'll meet
you at the forest I'm sure the pages are
still tucked in my waistcoat if you
don't mind the sight of a well my
decapitated skeleton they're yours my
decapitated skeleton
[Music]
all right so what is this over here
though
and why is it showing up as a quest item
okay so this tells you all right so this
part is
the same at least it seems like it's the
same right now that's the map that you
need
it doesn't to start be connected to the
missing pages best hang on to it for now
to start the next part of this Quest why
did you
see it neither
have a bit fine from the castle
you always find the map gotcha yeah
all right I'll see you there the only
way for me to get those pages I'll meet
you at the forest I'm sure the pages are
still tucked in my waistcoat and I think
it has to be night time right well all
right we already heard all that from you
let's go
okay so let's take a look at our Quest
because I know this part it doesn't show
you how to get there oh wait first we
have to return to scrope okay
all right so we're probably gonna have
to get by those dug bogs again
the guy stole a lot of things yeah seems
like it
bearded welcome in bearded how's it
going
oh man it would be so helpful if we
could fly away right now
come on swim faster
pushing L3 there we go
oh hey wait they didn't even detect me
so I'm just gonna go right along here
just don't mind me Doug bugs don't mind
me
I think we're level 12 or something
right now they were level 14.
yeah that you're right
you're right house so before the game
came out we had a chance to play Early
uh WB invited us out so we played the
game early and I was actually looking
for that secret cave someone had uh
someone at Avalanche had given me a hint
as to where I might find a little secret
and I I flew by here I flew by this area
so many times but never went right down
the cave just missed it
all right scrope hello scrope let's give
him the update you I was able to enter
apollonia's Grotto the toast was the key
I met a ghost there Richard jackdaw
who's agreed to lead me to the pages
I've been looking for oh that boy was
never good enough for Apollonia
sold it long ago sad news indeed as crap
she'll need to think of another way to
understand or scrope scrope takes some
consolation in knowing that the young
Slytherin found what they needed I did
thank you again scrope
your credit to house elves you're a
credit to ourselves
oh and he's gone
all right level 13 okay perfect we're
almost level 14. very nice
all right so now the next part of that
Quest
we go back into our menu here
uh it might it just hasn't okay I think
it's that right
or no that's a treasure okay hold on we
might need to just run around for a
second uh
get the next part of the quest to show
up
there it is right there
okay now if we go back in
we can just go ahead and fast travel
right over here
started your second play through this
morning bearded very nice
that is what uh this is our second
playthrough of course we
are doing a dark arts play through this
time
all right into the Forbidden Forest we
go
but it is daytime right now
it's very different in the day very very
different in the day
SP one more trophy for the Platinum nice
dude which one uh which one is it that
you still lack
that the collector's trophy or
one of the house ones
hey no problem Craig have a good one
appreciate you stopping by
e here I am as good as my word jackdaw
all right dude let's do this
we meet again Richard jackdaw
I suppose I shouldn't be surprised to
see you it took the cunning of a
Slytherin to track down these Pages well
said now where do we go from here follow
me I shall lead you as far as I can but
I fear I may remain a tad reluctant to
revisit the scene of My Demise keep your
eyes open for a bird bath when you find
it say intramuros intramural I think
it's Latin
or Greek as you can imagine I never paid
much attention in school
shall we
all right
gonna lead the way anything else
oh shoot I don't have spell diamonds
right now
oh
do we need lumos I'll put it on for now
but I feel like we're gonna need a
waterfall incendio for sure a lake if we
get inside here
because there are lots of spiders
surprising how much of this is rather
unfortunately coming right up there the
dark arts Arena
go ahead and activate this while we're
nearby
you know the closer we get the more I'm
remembering
probably best I leave you to it oh
you're leaving now of course you are
and you
well he was a lot of help
all right for now
oh man all these spells that I have are
good but all right we're in combat right
now so I'm not worried about lumos for
the moment
oh my goodness dude
wow enemies of a higher level will be
harder to defeat indeed they just
overwhelmed me very quick
let's just go ahead and get rid of you
right away with the coolest has to be
the coolest animation in the game I
think anyway the ancient Magic
wait where'd you go
all right we've got so many spiders in
here
oh dude we use that Wigan weld at the
last possible second
we're just way under leveled for these
guys right now
the problem
I think we can do it though first bit of
a challenge at all that we've had in
this playthrough which probably this is
a good reminder that I should go into my
gear
let me make sure we have everything
yeah see right there we did not have our
best gear on
so let's just double check see if we
have anything else
dude we definitely need a better
headpiece for sure for sure for sure
all right that's going to take it up 69
but I don't want to wear that so let's
turn that off
all right no upgrade there
and no upgrade there all right
so we don't have traits or anything we
don't have talents none of that yet
we're third we're level 13 though and
they're level 20. all right if I don't
beat it this time I might just try to
run by them but
there we go
dude he just has so much health
look at that man like we are barely
hurting him at all
and he won shots oh no he didn't ask her
all right let's get away from here
this is crazy
that though man like we're just barely
doing anything for his health
should probably upgrade there we go
there we go
gonna do more damage now
that one from afar is the one that keeps
shooting me then I keep hitting this
close one with Stupify
oh
hold on this might actually work
all right all right back up back up back
up don't want to get in there too far oh
dude I didn't even know we got hit
incendio
imagine we die when we got we've spent
so much time we've gotten them this low
oh he doesn't even look like he wants to
fight anymore he always kind of backing
up
Dodge out of the way
here we go all right
nice okay
now this one back here
oh okay look how quick we took that one
out just a big one
no no we cannot lose to the little guys
we cannot lose to the little woods
all right
see my first playthrough I probably
leveled up way more before I did this
yeah you guys are right we could use
potions too but I want to save see we've
got seven cabbages those could come in
handy and then we just have one of the
adoras potion so that's going to
increase our defense but yeah we'll save
both those
for a thief jackal's surprisingly this
is his word
no not that one let's go lumos
give ourselves a little bit more light
in here
foreign
skeins
I don't think there's anything we could
do right now to help them
here
I don't think that's actually the way
you're supposed to go but
it works something oddly solemn about
this place
such Regal creatures stacks
oh
such Regal creature Stags don't you guys
love the nod
don't you love the nod
long time Potter fans should definitely
recognize this area right here
there it is just this chapter described
I know it's so well done
so well done
runic with the posture check all right
we have to whisper the password Here
intramuros
it's a cool animation there also another
one from the trailer
oh
million eventually
this is the last one
all right man we need some range spells
desperately
I'm missing our range
all right with incendio you pretty much
have to pull them in because it's so
it's such a short range spell
all right jackdall's tomb here we go
Christy with a hydrate
yeah we do have Expelliarmus as well it
just doesn't do as much on this place
spiders
all right so now we're inside this is
not really a dark area so yeah we can go
ahead and put Expelliarmus back on
it would have definitely worked on the
Goblins though
all right so let's do a little revelio
here
these fruits
so I guess that is that the only
difference do you guys know in terms of
the quest just the lead up to it
and then from here on out I guess
everything's mostly the same right
s casual visitors down there
let us proceed get ready for the spiders
that's the only difference I I thought
so
I wonder if any of the respect me
through this
oh my gosh that is just so creepy
what level are they in here why is it
not showing me the level there it is 13
okay
does better than I thought it would
there's that last one
all right here we go
nicely done nicely done almost to level
14. Rebellion
my goodness look at all of them in there
oh that's so creepy
that is so creepy
lots of protego Stupify
I need to remember that
video
yo freaking nerds media coming in with
the raid
welcome in Raiders welcome in welcome in
thank you guys for being here
hope you all had a fantastic stream
we are currently on our second
playthrough of Hogwarts Legacy
and our first playthrough we were all
good good Gryffindor no unforgivables
and here with this playthrough we're
going the complete opposite
complete opposite
so we have named ourselves Lord retro
Mort
we're going full dark arts
but right now we are still very very
early in that
in that new uh new playthrough and we
just got the Spider Slayer armor with
the collection update all right very
nice okay so we cleared out this area
already it looks like we missed this
little
loot bag right over here and there you
go we actually needed an upgrade right
there for the first year cap
all right so let's unequip this one oh
wow that's a big jump right there 15 to
our defense
yes please
definitely take that
all right so I think we're supposed to
go why even though it's pointing me that
way
I think we're supposed yeah I was about
to say I think we're supposed to go down
here first
I remember this one the first time
through
all right so there's a lot that's right
there's so many different floats
straight to me
so many branching areas here that's
where they want me to go but I want to
explore this first I want to check this
out
that we can just go up the ramp here
yeah see we got more loot over here
another creepy spider
and we are on hard mode as well
we hadn't really had any problems until
right before the start of this Quest
there was
uh level 20 spider my gear slots are
full already
oh dude I'm so not used to the how many
do you start with 20 oh my gosh that's
just not enough
it's not enough all right let's destroy
a couple of these things though
uh we'll destroy one of the masks
all right so that opens up two slots
I really don't want to do a bunch of
Merlin puzzles again
guess that's the only way though if I
want to open up more oh we got a lot of
scarves here
that we are keeping
unnecessarily
okay that one will be an upgrade but we
just cannot equip it till we hit Level
14.
Marielle with the hydrate
what playthroughs have you done so only
one I just did my main Gryffindor
playthrough got that one to 100 percent
and then
this is my second
this is my second playthrough
but I was really I really wanted to take
my time with that first one you know I
was making a lot of content too like
tips and stuff for the game
and still have more of that that I need
to make
but yeah it was definitely time I was I
was excited about
starting something new fresh play
through that's odd I'd have thought
Jackal would have been interested in
this Loop there's no sign of him jackdaw
did not do a great job of looting this
cave I don't know if you guys knew that
or not if you played the game you should
definitely know because our character
makes reference to it a couple of times
oh wait hold on okay so 75
77 right there yeah let's go with that
for sure
but then I want to go back to the dark
arts
and then we have to put the hood on
again that's fine though
a little annoying you have to do it
every time especially in the early game
when you're switching out gear so much
but
all right so that was that I found that
looks like that's all that was in that
area
now we can proceed toward the marker
here
looks like we're gonna have some more
spiders waiting for us up here
oh my goodness Expelliarmus after
Stupify
who was that earlier Anna just saying
why aren't you using Expelliarmus yeah
apparently I was not giving it enough
credit because
that was uh pretty powerful right there
all right so we've got the two here
the only two this time or is there a
third one somewhere
but perhaps the next symbol is hidden
somewhere
oh there it is right there
just a little bit that wasn't too crazy
so on my Hufflepuff it's probably gonna
be my wife playing through on that one
yeah she does not normally play games
but she's watched me play this one
enough that she is intrigued
and she is a Hufflepuff I've already
made a character actually for her as a
Hufflepuff but I think we'll just delete
it and let her go through the Full
Experience herself at some point
and then I'll probably just do the
Ravenclaw will probably just be entirely
offline just getting just trying to get
that trophy
probably won't even play it all the way
through I don't know I might
might play it all the way through
all right so
all these little spiders we don't have
to worry about those
all right let's go ahead and check out
what's in this treasure
no saccharin you actually cannot change
the spells in the dark arts Arena it is
a set door left a little something
behind a set spell tree or spell diamond
in there
which is the only way I've gotten to use
the unforgivables at all was on that
play through doing that area
oh yeah I remember this spot right here
I remember this spot
Okay so we've got
another branching path
I think this way has a chest over here
and then I'm pretty sure the opposite
side does too that one
and then I think the way we're actually
supposed to go is just straight ahead
oh my gosh we're gonna fill up so quick
I should have went to sell no I'm gonna
destroy these
I did a lot of damage I should have went
to sell my gear before I'm just not used
to having to do that after
after my main playthrough having all the
Merlin trials complete and
oh my goodness there was still another
one
why can I not lock onto you
oh my goodness there's still a lot more
somehow
trying to save my Wigan welds I know I
have some guys I'm just trying to save
them
don't want to use them all
oh no
might not be able to save them here
for the office
you know what
not even risking it
hit it with the ancient magic there is
one more somewhere
all right there we go see now our health
is going to refill anyway
even on hard mode just have to clear the
area
all right so we have another chest here
oh my gosh another piece of gear that
we're not going to be able to carry
because we're gonna fill up soon
okay hold on you can actually can you
sneak through that area
I guess not
yeah we are in we are in hard mode now
yep
accio incendio and Expelliarmus work
wonders
oh yeah I see my wife reacting to the
game yeah that'd be fun that would be
fun
she's never appeared on stream at all
we got her to wave one time that was it
we got her to wave and she said goodbye
one night off off camera
all right so we have another chest over
here and then I'm pretty sure we're
supposed to just go straight ahead
just been interested in
this what the heck was jackdaw doing you
guys think when he was looting this cave
because he just did a terrible job
let's go
back here
oh come on wait what what was going on
right there
no
man we really need the upgraded version
of incendio too
and the dash I missed so many of the
things that you have access to by the
end of the game
yeah Expelliarmus right after the
Stupify when you have that bonus damage
it's really nice
all right we have uncollected rewards
and the challenges
that's awesome
all right this one right up here
in sight but I may as well help myself
to this not a headless skeleton in sight
all right we've got to be close to
getting full again
let's check our challenges here
it said we I thought it just said we had
one to
not there it is combat
all right Spider Slayer that's right we
are knocking out a lot of spiders in
this area
why only some people become ghosts in
the Harry Potter Universe there was
actually a Pottermore I'm pretty sure
there was a Pottermore post about that
or it might have been addressed briefly
in one of the books too but it's
basically it's it's like a a choice
and it's for
people that are kind of afraid of of
moving on
and a lot of the ghosts or sometimes
they'll usually end up regretting it
yeah I think there was a big Pottermore
update about that at one point
oh you're not in the book yet okay
gotcha yeah I think there's a piece on
that
Harry talks to nearly headless Nick
about it in in book five
all right so we cleared out
a couple of those man we still I'm
trying not to get rid of everything
though because we do need to
we do need to have a little bit of money
on this playthrough because we're not
okay that's a downgrade no point in that
but we did open up a few slots at least
okay
wasn't very thorough and as such of this
cave
Rebellion
yeah there's so many little
branching areas of this cave
honestly I don't even know how much it's
worth it I guess if I get a couple of
upgraded items then it would be but
not too many
are we doing a video chat stream
discussion I hope so yeah yeah once uh
Miranda finishes and and James I know
James is getting really close I want to
do another big
big kind of Round Table discussion with
a lot of creators
there's a few that that were still uh
not complete I don't want to rush them
either you know I was kind of joking
with them on Twitter saying come on I'm
waiting but in all seriousness I I hope
they take their time and enjoy it
yeah I still haven't even posted my
would have been interesting full like
extensive review of the game yet either
all right so we got that
dude this was a whole this was a
branching area too I don't even know if
I was supposed to
okay hold on we need to get back to
how do you get over there
and we need to stop it right here
jump all right nice
not a headless skeleton in sight nice
there's an upgrade okay I may as well
we need any upgrade we can get right now
playing on hard mode
okay that's gonna be plus six on our
offense
oh no scarf does not look good with the
with the hood up does not look good
okay we already got that one
look at that right there
little enchantment on the books I guess
okay so I think we can hop down now
Draco I just got the game guide in
yesterday and I haven't had a chance to
look through it yet I mean I skimmed
through it we talked a little bit about
it on stream last night on our YouTube
live there it is the bridge it's almost
complete
more spiders
all right dude you have to be really
focused on the combat when you're doing
hard mode
when you get surrounded by all these
spiders
got it okay and level 14.
no oh
this one's huge
all right you know what let's just go
ahead in ancient magic this one yep take
care of one of them right away
incendio
explaining all this nice
oh no is that the big one nope another
one of these guys
sorry Luna not right now I'll open the
door in a second
she wants out
oh wait defeat an enemy with a Chinese
chomping cabbage
all right well here you go go crazy
cabbage
go crazy
all right there we go we got that one
all right lift a scurrier while it's
burrowing okay that should just be
levioso right
all right let's hit it with that
okay wait for it right there nice okay
all the spiders
are gone at least for now
and hold on make sure we grab all the
loot I just keep having to remind myself
that loot is actually
valuable to me again on this on this
second playthrough
all right oh yeah there's one underneath
I do remember that
there's one right there
and then right there
and then where's the last one right
there
and also I did see there was another
chest down low you need to make sure I
grab that
all right let's go back down here
I think we still have some open gear
slots we just opened
oh another wig and weld potion anyway
our door wasn't very thorough dude are
you gonna make the comment every time
retro Ward every time we open the chest
I must be getting closer to Jack those
remains all the knights these are some
of my favorite enemies to fight in the
game once again Richard Jack duel
thank you for keeping these there he is
guys
here it is the map that brought your
doom Jack though
is there something Beyond this room
I think so I just wish I had the ancient
magic throw that could
send there
armor flying back at them
like right there
later in the game you unlock the ability
to
use the ancient magic throw to send it
flying back at them
oh
there we go
oh protego just in time
no I did it in the wrong order
got one more
should we collect all those for the
ancient magic all right incendio does a
decent job on those two
yeah exactly Cami like going back to not
having talents
and all of those
all right let's just hit you with an
ancient magic take care of that one
pretty quickly
[Music]
see does Expelliarmus work on you no way
no
I forgot you can't Dodge that one
or you can't uh protego that one
oh dude he
Wick
all right we need a wigging weld for
sure
all right you can't levioso them I
figured that much
all right looks like they don't have any
attacks that we can partake though
no
Rebellion
no not rafaelia
use there we go finally it's like use
your wiggin well
come on
all right got rid of him
love yourself
there we go
all right we found a few wig and mold
potions in here anyway so we didn't have
to use too many
but some thing
hold on I'm collecting collecting things
we'll get to that in a moment
hey grave Voyager Garb and it's an
upgrade
howling wolves welcome in thank you for
being here hope you're having a good day
all right so we cannot do anything with
that one yet
wait what
oh it wasn't it was the outfit
no if it gets level 15 before we can use
that one
all right fine fine
I think we're finally about to get the
trophy though for reaching the map
chamber as a Slytherin
I think we're about to get it
hey noob
welcome in noob
first time chatter is this your first
time chatting over here in this stream
new I know you said you didn't use
twitch a lot but
thank you for being here dude hope
you're having a good uh what is today
Wednesday Thursday
Wednesday hope you're having a good
Wednesday
so the people who kept saying this was a
water area
we're totally right
I didn't think it was I thought it
looked like fog back in the trailer
it's so cool it protects me until I'm
able to make my way out to them
I don't know what happens if you try to
go back
probably just suck at the door
what is this place
yes we're here
let's go
I wonder if the trophy pops
here in this cutscene or if it's not
until after
Hogwarts Legacy TV first time chatter
welcome in
bebu
how's it going thank you all for the
follows as well
can it be
and it'd be Percival Rackham the guy who
we thought to be Merlin
it could have worked if they tried to
maybe he's an heir of Merlin or
something even if he's not actually
Merlin
Lord retro more than the haunted map
chamber right nature dweller welcome in
nature dweller it's you as someone
finally found our map chamber I
recognize you from the pensives you'll
Professor we did now give me the trophy
please I must confess that I don't be
surprised to see someone so young
standing before me I'm the same age that
you and Isadora morganock were when you
see the hydrates in the chat I see you
paid attention
and might I presume you share our
ability
to see traces of ancient Magic
yes sir I do
as you have likely realized by now our
ability gives us a unique relationship
with all forms of magic we can access
expressions of Magic the few others can
opportunities will arise that allow you
to sharpen this rare Talent do not
squander them I won't Professor thank
you we are you sir we hear you to
discuss but first a map found in a
certain book LED you here place the book
on the pedestal I don't have the book
with me sir hmm that is unfortunate I'm
afraid
no turn with the book
uh why is this called the map chamber we
already know that
Spring Book I'll retrieve the book right
away good we shall speak again once the
book is in place
yes finally talents your connection to
ancient magic has unlocked talents you
will receive one Talent Point each time
you increase your Wizarding level you
have new Talent points to spend in the
talents menu in your Field Guide
let's go okay we have 10 Talent points
available there it is there's the trophy
for reaching the map chamber as a
Slytherin the toast of the town
very nice very nice
okay so we are only what level we're
level 14 right now so we can do the one
for expelli armisto and we're going full
dark arts this time so I mean
yeah dude yeah
gonna go ahead and acquire this one
I'm gonna go ahead and acquire this one
and definitely this one Stupify has the
same effect as a curse on enemies cursed
enemies take increased damage
so have to make sure we get all those
I'll probably do all of I don't think
we're gonna do any stealth or room of
requirement
because let's see that would be we could
do all of these and that's 36.
oh but hold on we had 10 so there's four
there's four levels so I guess levels
one through four you don't get Talent
points for
because we hit Level 14 and when we
started this we had 10 Talent points
available
all right so I know there's a lot of
good ones in the core too
so basic cast reduces spell cooldowns
yes that's a must
a successful protego will contribute to
the ancient magic meter
ancient magic throw yes that's the one I
want so you can throw the uh
the disarmed weapons
oh spell Diamonds though
absolutely have to do the spell diamonds
honestly these are the first two I
should have done
first two I should have done you have
those are just a must an absolute must
oh we could also unlock the Dodge as
well oh man there's so many good ones
here I'm gonna do let's see we've got
three left okay so let's do this one
this one
and then let's go here and do
the ancient magic I don't know if I'm
gonna go
as hard on the ancient magic for this
playthrough because I'm gonna have the
unforgivables and so I need to make sure
that I leave room basically to do
I mean definitely that one
definitely that one
definitely that one that one probably
the flippindo one too
oh so yeah I have to make sure that we
save room for all of those
so ancient magic I'm gonna hold off on
Ancient magic for now but the Dodge is
so important
I feel like we want the the Swift
dodging for sure
all right
that alone is going to make a huge
difference that little upgrade right
there
somebody was just saying in the chat
like not having the talents
it really does make a big difference
all right so now we've got our Dash back
it's gonna be able to put a curse on
people with Expelliarmus and with our
protegos stupefy
should be doing a lot more damage now
just with all of that alone
yeah adding spell slots I know right
imagine if I'd forgotten that one why
would I need the book all right and
speaking of that let's go ahead and edit
those right now so I'm gonna make this
one kind of our utility area for now
and then the top one the top one's good
we are totally good and that's all the
Spells we know right now one two three
Let's see we got one two three four five
six seven yeah so that's we have
everything mapped so we've got to
completely open slot right now as soon
as we start unlocking more spells we'll
be able to use that for something
different so right now this is kind of
our main combat right here
and then we have these down here for
utility and such
unlock another one of those all right
let's see what our next Quest item is
jackdaw's rest exit the map chamber okay
I could do that
I don't remember if something happens
here at the end if there's something
else I have to do or
they literally just want you to walk out
is it
you're directly under Hogwarts I mean
this this brings you right out by the
yeah
right here I want
I wonder I did promise him I wouldn't
neglect my studies while he was away
suppose I have enough to distract myself
with till he returns with a book
oh hold on I know for sure there are a
bunch of
isn't the dragon near here the little
dragon statue
oh we can't get into this room yet
there's definitely a revelio page in
there and then I know for sure there's
one right here in front of the Dragon
yeah
can help us level up too the Hogwarts
motto Draco dormians nunquam titilandis
means never tickle a sleeping Dragon
fortunately this particular sleeping
dragon is made of stone and will never
awaken it may be tickled to absolutely
no effect
useful for pushing objects or
adversaries away
I'm ready for defendo Sharp that's the
one we want
Rebellion
urn of Ashes this particular urn is
rumored to have once borne the
inscription Pioneer in Dragon taming
should not have started with the
Hungarian horntail
yeah nature drawer we do stream on both
mainly here
this one's for gameplay but we do a
little bit of gameplay over on YouTube
as well
all right how many of you guys
have found this secret right here
how many of you have found this thing
this is really cool so look at that
nothing when you do revelio
nothing
at all but if you look at your map look
at that look at that mini map
it looks like there should be something
behind there took you all gave to find I
know look at that man just hidden in
plain sight
and I think we could do the next part
too I don't think there's any uh
there's not an alohomori or anything
this is such a cool room right here
let's see where is the
yeah right over here at the beginning
so here's the field guide page for it
werewolf Saga tapestries this set of
tapestries tells the tragic tale of a
witch bitten by a werewolf she chose to
flee from her home to protect her infant
daughter and husband rumor has it that
her daughter fell asleep to the howl of
a wolf for years thereafter
now you might think that's where the
secret ends
but remember it said it tells the story
so if you walk around here and just get
a good look at all these pictures here
so here you have the mom and the
daughter right there
and then you have them here with kind of
a traveling party
same thing looks like they're out on a a
hunt
and then they encounter a werewolf
the father you could see holding the
baby trying to protect the baby and the
wife she's standing behind him right
here there's the werewolf
and then right here
they show her with the baby they show
the family and what is that one is that
one like
oh maybe this is a nurse or something
you think
maybe maybe she was bitten between this
one and this one and we don't see it
and then right here
it looks like he has just gotten some
bad news
and then here's the crazy part guys if
you get close and you cast lumos lumos
look at that
look at that she moves behind the tent
and she just looks
very distraught at this moment
so we go to the next one here
look at her look at that now she's
crying
oh that one's crazy
then it looks like they're hunting her
but now she's she's running away
is what I get from it that's my
interpretation of it then we go back to
this one lumos
and again
it looks like they're hunting her at
this point she's running away
let me go right here
and now she's watching them as they're
kind of traveling back home
my interpretation of the story and then
probably the saddest one of all
or transformation is now complete into
the werewolf and you gotta think this
was probably long before the wolf Spain
potion was a thing
it was way more manageable once
Lupine you know in Harry Potter's day
when Lupine was a werewolf way more
manageable
oh
so sad right
so sad
she had to leave the family behind the
newborn the newborn child
but yeah I just thought this was such a
cool room
such a cool little trick which to me
I mean think about that that's like
really the only time I've seen a
mechanic like this in the whole game I
don't recall seeing that type of
mechanic
anywhere else I mean lumos you use to
kind of reveal certain things but not
like in that way
so to me I'm still hoping that there are
secrets out there that people
haven't even found yet and that we'll
find for hopefully
weeks months who knows maybe even years
there are sometimes games that you know
years go by before people find all of
the secrets and like that that whole
thing with lumos right there you don't
have to do that like it's not necessary
for the field guide page or anything
you can find the field guide page
without that where is this
speaking of field guy page maybe it's
below this
oh maybe I can't get in there yet where
it is
just gonna go to hogsmead we definitely
need to sell some stuff don't even have
the room of requirement yet
when can we finally get a broom man
it takes so long to get a broom
dude it's so quiet
still closed
yeah I think you have to get the quest
first with your flying class
hello sir
don't mind me
oh darn it that's right
we need to sell stuff first
there we go sell with this guy familiar
face
how's it going Thomas
I need to sell a lot of things let's
sell this uh actually hold on let's just
do a quick scan through of everything
is anything that we have an upgrade that
is but we cannot equip it yet
and so is that that one we can equip
Okay so
you
all right so now basically everything
until we get to
the grayed out one right there
now this
it looks like it's already telling me
that it's going to be a downgrade so I
don't know if there's really a point in
deeming it
it's gonna sell it who cares
Conjuration Spell crafts we don't I
didn't realize you could buy these
before you even unlock the remote
requirements anything else I can do to
help
will do Thomas we'll do
all right so now let's go back in here
we should be able to grab this no
problem
blood red fedora
now we need we need to go back and sell
again
because we only have 20 slots
oh my gosh dude
that actually goes kind of well together
goes kind of well together not gonna lie
I think it goes better than that
I feel like that works better
all right so let's put the other hat on
get a slight upgrade there
disable that
all right do we have anything else that
was an upgrade nothing there nothing
there
that one we don't have it unlocked yet
all right we could sell that mask now if
we needed to just gloves
all right and then we can sell that too
okay let's just go sell those while
we're here we might as well
while we're already here because it's
just gonna get so tedious
especially in this playthrough because I
don't even know if I'm gonna do many of
the Merlin
puzzles on this playthrough to be honest
with you
let me know if there's anything else I
can do to help
all right so let's check our Quest page
now
and see where we're supposed to go there
it is flying class
yes
finally
all right before we activate that I want
to make sure that I unlock this flu
flame location
go ahead ignatia
say it
come on I know you want to
best I've ever heard ignatia you guys
she didn't say a word wait did was there
a banned word
placed upon you ignatia
guys if you're watching over on YouTube
if you're catching the replay of this I
am currently under a banned word right
now in our live stream
there's a specific word that I can't say
let's see if you all can guess it
you want to leave a comment below trying
to guess which word it just happens
it just so happens to be on screen right
now okay forget guessing because it just
popped up at that very moment so I had
to comment on it and it's not begin
I'll tell you that it's not begin
all right Madame Kagawa let's do this
your attention please sorry Madame
Kagawa everyone please welcome a new
student to our flying class off on
another adventure I know she didn't say
anything to all of you how to maneuver
on a broomstick safely as broom flight
is faster they didn't say anything about
it in the past Draco this I fear some of
you have forgotten
diving rolling and loop the loops come
on I just want the broom
practice
practice for those who need a refresher
step up to it hey have a good one
saccharin thank you for stopping by
leg over and rest your weight on the
seat
up
I mean this was so similar to the scene
from the first movie right
I mean almost down to you
going and doing something that you
weren't exactly supposed to do
[Music]
one leg over so there's a leg on each
side
none of that side settled nonsense a
gust of wind will throw you right off
that's okay we'll be fine
there he goes Everett
how long into the game do you unlock the
broom so the in-game counter set about
five hours yourself at once but I don't
think it's counting menu time and
cutscene time
good now
Courtyard dude it feels a lot longer
than that
I will say I want them returned the hang
of this even on my first playthrough I
felt like it was taking a really long
time
hey Alicia with a gifted sub now that
you're to our friend JP raven fire
we got it Madame Kagawa give us that
speed boost that's what we need
wait where am I supposed to go
over here
thank you for that Alicia and uh JP
enjoy your ad for you viewing on the
channel
and access to all the emotes
as well
dude I feel so slow after having broom
fully upgraded wish you could have
experience
yeah me too Everett
me too is that a tease for another
another game possibly
[Music]
it'd be weird playing as such a small
kid
are there any I mean I'm trying to think
of any video games where you play
as a really young child
huh a giant squid I love that they put
that in there
maybe
um
I guess in The Last of Us Ellie is I
think 14 that's the first game
and then maybe brother a tale of two
sons that kid's probably pretty young
[Music]
bully
good one
how old are you in Bully I don't
remember
yeah there's a lot of flashback
sequences in games good points did you
fly through those Rings look at that
scene right there
gold broom well enough
I feel like a bit more challenging
myself we haven't properly met I'm
Everett klopton am I right and
suspecting that a Slytherin like you
might be interested in making an escape
absolutely Everett
I can't say no to that
mind a bit of a detour so to speak I
mean seeing that shot right there I just
instantly think give it here Malfoy
or I'll knock you off your broom
Courtyard hello let's hope the
Headmaster isn't having tea by the
window today
it's all good
they they nailed the flying scheme dude
it's just so fun
[Music]
what's crazy is
the Beast flying wait where are we
supposed to go there he is
the Beast wine looks amazing
I just the broom man the broom is just
so quick
helpful if you need to escape situation
yeah that extra bit of speed it's more
like it there's some balloons we can go
and pop
there's the famous bridge it almost
serves as like a little outdoor tour
Hogwarts too I love it
that's a bit of solid architecture isn't
it like for people who may not be as
familiar with the the castle on the
grounds
[Music]
whistle this concludes our tour let's
hurry back
[Music]
all right dude he just had a surge of
speed right there
nature dweller have a good one thank you
for stopping by
have a great rest of your day
[Music]
Bean
oh hello Professor we were trying to get
a bit of extra practicing Hefty points
will be taken from each of you or not
following my instructions
he didn't even look like he cared
class because you're still because
you're still not showing yourself or
waldermore
class is finished for the day
thank you madam cagawa I just want to go
buy a broom now that's for you
you do well to use better judgment look
at this eyes
they were huge for a second that was
some rather good fly
see she was impressed she was impressed
waldemore thank you so much for that sub
very much appreciate it my friend good
to see you again you have to admit those
views were worth it
you seem at home on a broom but if you
had a fancy model you could fly laps
around Imelda she's kagawa's favorite
I could show her a thing or I don't
remember hate having to return the
school broom after class perhaps after
purchase a broom there yes you can you
should
I wish I could I recommend visiting Alby
weeks at spint which is in hogsmead he's
always yeah I think we can go straight
there
I'll keep an eye out for you in the sky
I'm pretty sure we can go straight there
now to buy one
let's see let's go to our hogsmeade map
all right he's right there by this flu
Flame
I think it's time
I think it's time for confringo
serious welcome in serious how's it
going
all right
it is officially open just gonna let
them finish talking
idea
yes and that's room of requirement
wait what did he just say about Beetle
The Bard
I missed it
I'm gonna have to go back and watch that
I think it was these two guys talking
right here
he said something about Beetle The Bard
what was it
I'm gonna have to go back and look at
that new face wonderful before we do
that let's get this field guy page
spintwich's sporting needs run by the
amiable Alby weeks the shop sells all
manner of Wizarding Sporting Goods
including the latest broom models gossip
around town is that Albie himself is
working on a number of broom
enhancements grab this right here and we
just got another Talent Point Let's Go
another that's going to be an upgrade
there very nice
all right Alby can I buy a broom sir
this is it Alby wakes At Your Service
welcome
came by before and weren't able to come
oh that's interesting yeah I don't I
don't know I had to travel took me a
while to get the broom both times and
I've only just returned thankfully with
inventory I presume you're in the market
for a new broom got a few yes
Silver Arrows win wisps too no matter
what broom you choose you'll be pleased
they're all exceptional both in quality
and three minutes to go on our word band
guys
all right I'll have a look
yes I definitely want an array of brooms
I'll have a look around thank you
what are we looking for today yes
finally okay we got Ember Dash Hogwarts
house broom Moon trimmer broom
the wind wisp broom
and the you Weaver broom
I want to look at Ember Dash that item
is if the highest quality there's Ember
Dash there's the I'm pretty sure I
bought the Hogwarts house broom on my
first playthrough
I feel like Ember Dash
feel like Ember Dash I promise
oh you're trying to make me say the
banned word look at you
look at you all sneaky on us
Draco have I seen any funny interactions
in the hospital
involving a goat
s just the other day
you say some enhanced
hands go on yeah we gotta have a speed
booster about you I think you'll be
quite happy with the performance of any
broom at lower altitudes but you might
notice that speed consistency tends to
falter as you rise you get higher that
yellow meter this issue goes faster some
ideas for enchantments upgrades if you
will that will improve the performance
of any broom you fly what I need is
someone to conduct a broom flight and
report back to me so I can perfect the
upgrades as it happens
you can do that is using abandoned broom
courses for time trials clever girl an
ideal situation for collecting flight
statistics if you were to compete you
saw the goat interaction to um so funny
hey have a good one Professor spells
thank you for being here today and I see
a hydrate redeemed in the chat too
that sounds intriguing I'll see what I
can do thank you it'll be worth your
while intriguing the new upgrade ought
to enhance brooms in every regard and I
can give you a special price
the time trial should be a bit of fun
too go to the Quidditch and a mill
delays will sort you out
all right once you've beaten him out as
time be sure to let me know
okay I have to beat her time and then we
can come back
so I'm just gonna go ahead and fast
travel there
we also have these options too Perry
Pippin demanding delivery
some rewards for that and then follow
the butterflies
all right so let's go back to the
my best to do the Hogwarts map right
oh and then we have these so we've got
rumor requirement and then we also have
in the shadow of the undercroft yes
that's where we get confringo
one of the more powerful spells in the
game for sure
I feel like anyway
okay wait why can I not
right there that's what we need and what
is this one oh summoner's Court
right we could knock those out too
an imposter check redeemed as well
make sure we're sitting nice and
straight guys
nice and straight
oh dude that makes such a difference
and with today's patch update you no
longer have that little flashing that
always happened right after you hopped
on the Broom
if it isn't slytherin's newest brim
Talent yeah let's go Imelda hello Imelda
let's destroy this time right here
with his broom upgrade
I tried to help him once he nitpicked my
flying technique and that was the end of
that the nerve why is he roping you into
his brim testing silliness you've barely
started flying from what I know caught
wind of you showing just you wait Imelda
you sound jealous seems someone's
jealous of my skills on a broom
she is very snarky jealous of you
everyone knows that question Captain
there's no quiddish this year though
but for some reason now people think
your competition
I can't be having that perhaps I am
competition oh it can't be what passes
for a Slytherin these days
ragged old house dropping at standards
tell her retro more
one way to find out who's who's their
flyer do you guys catch that slightly
different dialogue there for being in
Slytherin let's see if
you let's go why not I can be yours
I've seen you lose
[Music]
all right this might be a little bit of
a challenge not having the speed boost
I went back recently and did this on my
main playthrough
having all of the
room upgrades unlocked and it obviously
makes
big difference
it is a little bit different though when
you're doing this because you get
you can keep the Boost meter
by going through more of those
little yellow bubbles right there
all right so best time is 220 I can't
remember what I have on my main account
[Music]
Village
the village of hogsmead
music too it's so good
[Music]
this takes me back to Goblet of Fire
any of you have watched our Goblet of
Fire Let's place
there's a part that looks very similar
to this spot right here when you're
flying away from the Dragon
for the first task
obviously a immensely upgraded Graphics
that we have here nowadays but
imagine if the dragon flew by right now
oh
yeah so when you hit all these you can
basically just keep holding L2 the whole
time
134 no missed rings
that should be plenty to destroy
imelda's time
see how upset she is about it
see how upset
you must have cheated
fine come on now you won come on don't
think this is over he's so bad at the
races Damien
surely my win means it takes a little
bit to get used to for sure
okay she's coming around she's coming
around
I don't want your respect
see Lord retro Mort though he's not just
a straight up jerk I feel like he would
be a little bit smarter and more
strategic than than Voldemort so like we
we see Imelda as a potential ally
so I'm not gonna say I don't want your
respect I do want her respect she could
be I mean she's in our house too she's
in Slytherin we don't want to upset
things within our own house so I'm gonna
say all right accepted then perhaps you
have what it takes after all we shall
see but don't get your hopes up the next
course near Irondale offers a much
tougher challenge
you can try to prepare by erasing this
course again just checking at the podium
where the leaderboard is you can check
your time and start the race
we'll see next time if your win here was
more than oh we'll see
well you'll see Imelda I'll be weeks
just wait till I upgrade my broom even
further
return to the podium to challenge other
Racers and Advance your way through the
ranks of the leaderboard let's see where
I met on the leaderboard Ruby
goodness Ruby
we can't miss the week so be glad to
hear how I felt we can't have Ruby
beating us but I don't know if we can
improve on that time much without
upgrading things so
back to hogsmead we go whoops hit the
wrong one
oxme map all right and then
let's check back in with Alby here give
him our update
and I think it gives you a broom upgrade
right away if I remember correctly
I think you have to buy it but still
we've something to report iron all right
let's see I think oh goodness it's 22. I
would 22 minutes on that one chat
the the band word is complete
we do not need to say or we can we can
now say
Quest once again I was able to set a
record on my broom incredible Miss Rays
must have been shocked tell me how was
the bro she was not happy and it's
wanting for a bit of speed but it fed
well enough yeah we need more speed I'll
be speed left on certain turns heard us
like swoosh when I dipped oh thank you
hmm that's precisely what I needed to
know
oh you wanted me to say the other one
Mario
the other options even the nice Sayers
will be forced to admit that my works
are potential all along
can't wait to hear more excited to hear
more I have a very good feeling about
this upgrade I
thought hmm hell so you can't get it
from him right I don't think he upgraded
anything right there all right so I was
wrong about that I guess you do have to
come back later
so let's see you can see your if you go
into your gear yeah we don't have any
room upgrades yet so I think we have to
wait a little bit some time has to pass
all right so that would take us up to 30
so yeah the green one's actually going
to be
the best upgrade all right so let's go
put the dark arts back on
if we have any upgrades there nope
nothing there
and again because gear space is so
scarce oh wait I did unlock a wand
handle that I forgot to equip I think
dude that one actually
I mean
that one doesn't look bad it's the only
one we have right now our Slytherin
Slytherin playthrough
oh you think you guys think I should try
to go right back in and see if I can buy
it
back here again
today yeah I mean you could buy another
broom but I don't think you can buy an
upgrade or anything
oh wait that's right I can sell to you
too perfect
thanks for stop
oh you'll definitely see me again I'll
be you will see us again for sure
okay so quests which we can now say
again I want to do this one I want to do
in the shadow of the undercroft
let's go ahead and get that spell
that opens up a lot of uh there's some
other areas where you can get Field
Guide pages that you couldn't before
so let's go ahead and do that we need to
go back to Hogwarts
and let's see go into this one right
here
no maybe this one
and this one oh my goodness Luna you
went out again
you want out again
came back
I think she smells my wife cooking out
there
she smells the food
all righty let's see while we're here
lumos
see if I can remember where that one is
off the top of my head I actually don't
oh wait I think you either have to go
I have to go upstairs maybe
do you want
wait is it this was it this one
hold on hold on this is looking very
familiar
where are you little moth there you are
lumos
dude it is crazy how the brain works
sometimes right like I
I did not feel like I remembered where
that was at all and then
just naturally that's the direction I
started heading
and then it started coming back to me as
I as I went that way
right so this will give us a page right
here I mean the pages are great even
though I've already gotten all of those
on my main playthrough they're great
because they give you lots of experience
which
I'm not gonna need to hit max level on
this character but since we're playing
on hard I definitely want those Talent
points
you definitely want a lot of those
Talent points
so we can be
for sure we need all the dark art stuff
for sure
all right Sebastian time to introduce me
to the undercroft
I'm curious to see how ominous reacts to
you already knowing you because I'm a
Slytherin on this playthrough so we
actually already met
Sebastian where's my first playthrough
Thomas and I had not met at all glad you
received my owl
I have something to show you first let
me thank you for what you did let's do
it of course scripting tried to give me
detention but I have ways out of these
things well you took the fall for me and
that counts for something did you find
what you were looking for I did
something was missing
I'm not sure here is the best place to
discuss it understood we can talk more
in a moment in the undercroft not even
the professors know about this place
the Sebastian he thinks he's
manipulating me
no
I'm Lord retro more we are planning
Sebastian to be our right hand man
it's well disguised as we take over the
Wizarding World
that's what we're setting up here
so we got to be very careful in our
dialogue with him very carefully
yeah that's true Draco confringo
definitely helps a lot with the Merlin
puzzles too
that's what I was trying to say there's
a few areas with Field Guide pages but
Merlin puzzles a lot more
he named it the undercroft
I'm gonna be honest with ominous too
with my sister
see how it plays out she loved that
infernal game
what I wouldn't give to lose to her
again oh I should tell you I swore to
ominous I would Safeguard this place
lumos so please keep this between us
just teach me
but he's trusted me since the day we met
I wouldn't want to jeopardize that we
used to sneak in here almost daily
we've never been caught
think about confringo too is that means
we're one step closer to
getting to the unforgivable the start of
the unforgivables met him in our common
room
I've noticed he uses his wand to
navigate the castle he does no idea how
though ominous was born blind and no
spell could reverse it his one seems
almost
not surprising Lord retro a word band
you mean the wand chooses the wizard is
that how he found this place no someone
in his family knew about it
the gaunts are full of secrets I've
never heard I love that they put a gaunt
in this game I'm certainly never seen
anyone else here again mention this to
no one
especially ominous he has no love lost
for his family or their secrets but this
place is special to him of course
omena spoke to me about his family when
we first met to say that he has no love
lost for them is an understatement glad
you understand yep anyway
the undercroft has been a perfect place
to sneak off to away from prying eyes
you don't think he had reacted
differently otherwise at least hidden
spells really
like what like the blasting curse yeah
it's not an appropriate spell to teach
let's go
that's ridiculous magical education
ought to include all magic my thoughts
exactly
Bell like confringo is only truly
dangerous in untrained hands such spells
should be properly taught not banned to
be fair I'm admittedly partial to more
fiery forms of magic but you should
learn it
I can teach it to you safely here
it may take a while to get the feel for
it mimic my wand movement
Sebastian plays such a huge part even in
the main story very well like you have
his side stuff
but then he plays into several
main story moments too
you're getting it all right now the
question ready to try it out
the targets though
where do we map it we don't have
anything mapped here so
right there for now
all right
both have their uses especially I think
you'll find that a confronted
nice work
hot
you'll get used to it
that hot I
thought well done
very nice
I have to say I enjoyed that before Oh
man listen I practice confringo we
singed our eyebrows look at the Glee in
his eyes I haven't paid to see that I
swore we'd never live it down to this
day there's something about that spell
that's addictive there's a few more
spells Sebastian
I'm ready for more yes exactly the type
of magic I've been hoping to learn
there's more where that came from
been practicing similar spells here for
ages although I didn't tell Ann and
ominous about everyone I haven't been
here in some time
I'm sorry about your sister
if there's anything I can do perhaps
when I next head to felcroft you could
come along
Me Tan
she could use some cheering up
just let me know when and I'll meet you
oh she misses Hogwarts she's been stuck
at home with our Guardian Uncle Solomon
unfortunately he'll have to meet him too
well meeting a new student will be
precisely what she needs I shall look
forward to it cheers
by the way
I couldn't discuss out in the hall
earlier I'm not sure where to start you
said something was missing from what you
found in the library I assume it's to do
with what you told me about the poor key
and gring gods and ran wrong no nothing
gets past you and yes it is as I'm sure
you suspect there is a bit more to all
of this I'm listening
I need him on my side so
like I said we want him to be Lord retro
Mort's right-hand man in our rise to
power so I'm ready to tell him I have no
loyalties to Fig you must promise to
keep this between us I trusted you with
knowledge of the secret santa Croft here
we go you can trust me all right
because he traitors of ancient Magic
I don't know what I was expecting to say
but it wasn't that
what does that even mean honestly I'm
not entirely certain
all I know is that I can see Whispers of
an old magic that hardly anyone else can
fig and I think that ranrock has somehow
found a way to harness that Magic's
power are you telling me that goblins
may be wielding some sort of wizard
magic that's what we're trying to find
out and this ability of yours
does this allow oh you can see he's
already
starting to think about no well when you
do know tell me I've been studying
archaic forms of magic for ages yeah
perhaps we can help each other in the
meantime with both Rookwood and ranrock
after you I suspect a bit more time
practicing the blasting curses in order
spend as much time here as you'd like
and remember keep this place between us
oh
see I like ominous too though we need we
need ominous for our rise to power as
well the gaunt family could be very very
important to us
to Lord retro Mort here
I still feel like
oh man
he knows either way because I I've
already given him the other answer oh my
good playthrough
you that
I was just heading to our common room
I've recognized that voice you're the
new fifth year did did you come from the
undercroft
how did you get in there
so first playthrough I said I stumbled
upon it
oh man
oh man he knows either way I know guys
but I'm we're sticking with the Lord
retro Mort role play here
all right they both both of them need to
learn early on that we are the leader in
this so
Sebastian is just gonna have to get over
it
actually Sebastian brought me there but
he made it perfectly clear to keep quiet
so we're gonna be uh we're gonna be
honest with ominous
and not even your precious Professor
Phil will be able to help you oh he's
mad he's friends with the Headmaster and
I'm not afraid to exploit that
connection if I need to oh wait until my
father hears about this
all right I'm gonna tell him no need for
threats you needn't threaten me I'm not
going to say anything about your
undercroft why should I trust you
just betrayed Sebastian please I was
trying to defend him absolutely clear
that this is a secret place and I was to
tell no one he's a good friend I don't
need you to tell me about my oldest
friend oh it's interesting to see the
differences I know what you meant
Sebastian gets himself in enough trouble
he doesn't need your help and how it
gets back to kind of the same outcome
Sebastian is going to get an earful
about this that's pretty much where you
hit end up on the other option two now
the next time I talk with Sebastian
it'll be interesting to see if he's
upset about it yeah he he gets angry
either way exactly hope you all have a
fantastic rest of your day appreciate
the new Subs the new follows the
donations and I'll talk to you again
soon guys have a good one
foreign